let's do this hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to ultimate
custom night
how y'all doing I am still sick and I
don't know why my throat is doing better
it hurts like hell like others body ache
and his super simplest just been
pervasive for almost a week now so thank
you everybody so much for joining us
I know I said that I was done with
ultimate custom night and that's pretty
much true I'm not gonna be going for
fifty twenty mode I have no ambition to
do that and I wanted to clear up a
common misconception that people seem to
have is that I wasn't enjoying myself
when I was playing this game I want to
be very clear this is my favorite custom
night ever of any of the five nights at
Freddy's games even of the fan games
this is my favorite custom I just
because it let me go about in my own way
and I already knew that I didn't care
about the score I really didn't care
about getting the high score or anything
and I already knew that I didn't want to
go chase 5020 mode especially now that I
consider it to be pretty much
functionally impossible to do it in a
straightforward manner without relying
on complete or in Jesus to help you out
there Thank You Scarlet Raven I hope you
feel better soon with a hundred dollar
super jet you don't you don't need to
give me absolutely anything but thank
you so much for that Thank You Jamie
Denmark I wanted to say thank you
because of you my channel has gained
over 50 subscribers in two days I now
have a hundred and thirteen because you
noticed me well I guess this [ __ ] is a
shout out so that's cool for you but
also that's borderline self-promotion
there and thank you everybody so much
for joining us here on this wonderful
wonderful day so anyone that was saying
that I wasn't enjoying myself when I was
playing this absolutely wrong I've been
sick the past few days and so it comes
down to a matter of me just trying to
get through this without dying
and so the sickness has been very very
very
to me and I don't know why but in this
dream what I want to do is I want to
chase down the last few secrets of this
game and the first one that I want to go
for here is actually from Ned Ned has
this one voice line that is bizarre to
say the least so we're gonna get into
this object load it up and it's just
gonna be here while I talk cuz with Ned
he's gonna come shooting down here if
he's smart enough which you never know
with Ned but yeah he's just got this
weird voice line here he comes oh man it
moves like crazy and then I want to I
want to get the the cutscenes from
starting up on the the point increments
and I got to figure out if it's actually
every 700 or every thousand so I'm gonna
try to do 500 more than I had before
because it it should be uh uh it should
Marcos sick like the vid to make him
feel better
I don't think that's how I don't think
that's how I don't think that's how
YouTube works if it did man I'd feel it
feel incredible by now yeah let's see
you're only at 4000 and everyone else is
7000 above yeah I don't care about the
score I really don't I never did I knew
that approaching this game like I just
chasing the score was gonna drive you
crazy and the last thing that I needed
was to be driven crazy so I actually I
had a great time so when it came down to
me playing this game I had no ambition
to even go for the high score in the
first place I didn't I didn't really
care about beating anybody to the thing
and a lot of people need to realize that
this isn't really a competition as many
of the other people that stream this
game to sadly they're all working
together I made the video last because I
wanted to share my strategies and the
few things that I learned to try to make
it a little better come on Ned bear I
know you ain't you ain't probably
tricked by this maybe you is no no this
way oh okay you can go that way if you
want to now come on Ned bear come on
come on kill me come on come on there
beer Ned Neddy boy Ned Ned y'all right
there Ned are
don't you hate getting killed by obscure
secondary characters ya do ya do ya do
ya do ya turn on visual effects it why
would you want to turn them on what
would that even do what's that gonna do
what's that gonna do for me this is
gonna make Ned in extreme HD fidelity
over here
netball go get extreme HD - a first time
I ever got one no flat-screen TVs been
using the CRT for the rest of my entire
existence is what I call fancy right
here no this is no it's fancy oh come on
Ned come on come on Ned come dead dead
come on here there you go ahead all
right now you can make it if I open the
duct No Ned Ned Ned boy come on man he's
got one voice line it's probably gonna
take a bit Ned I love Ned Ned yeah but
Ned's got uh it's got a voice line
that's really really interesting to see
I Oh for some people saying like also I
wanted to mention
5020 mode was a 55 mode was a
ridiculously good challenge for me I'd
say that the way I played 55 mode was
exactly what I wanted out of this game
and what I wanted out of this game was a
test of skill I've built up a lot of a
lot of a skill over my time playing this
game and when I say like I built up
skill I built up this ability to click
buttons really fast on the screen so
when it comes down to 55 mode it was an
excellent test because it was exactly
borderline with a lot of the other 20
modes that I play to this game and it
gave me this clear path where I could do
it based on my skill alone because
number one I want to be very clear I'm
not criticizing anyone the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
okay I'll try to get Ned bad number
can't find it out I want to be out of
your clear
I I'm not criticizing anyone else's
methods for beating 20 mode but I am of
the firm belief that the the trick
stranger damn it come on the trick where
you can defeat the plushy animatronics
by keeping the camera on camera - I'm
almost convinced that's a glitch and not
actually a feature of the game because
what it does my my criteria for
bypassing it like characters like that
is whether or not it defeats them
through the mechanics of which they were
meant to be defeated or if it bypasses
them completely and getting around
buying the plushies is removing an
entire mechanic that I feel is integral
to the game and that's collecting coins
and and and I feel like that's almost a
bug and I'm not criticizing anyone for
do it because honestly the game is
unfair fifty twenty modes unfair do
whatever it takes to get to there but
it's not how I wanted to play
I like playing this game because I'm
able to really like show my skill in
terms of learning adaptability finding
the right methodology you know getting
getting the skills built up in terms of
muscle memory and like the other things
that I want knowing the knowledge of it
and getting dead come on boy Ned Ned
come on boy
Ned no I'm not talking about anyone
particularly anyone can do whatever they
want in this game like I said not
criticizing anyone like but for me
personally that's why 55 mode was the
perfect challenge for me because it
allowed me to be as flexible as I wanted
to be without necessarily going
overboard in terms of your guard now
what I'm trying to do here is I'm trying
to get a very rare voice line from Ned
bear and I don't know if there's other
criteria for getting it maybe another
thing where you have to die when he's
like level one and I'll try that next
but uh if it is then and maybe that's
gonna
then maybe that's gonna be the thing
that triggers it cuz I think it's like
very rare to die when he's level one cuz
I think I can get him there just as
easily with level one
as I could with anything else yeah yeah
so it's pretty cool
oh thank you - oh man there's been so
many super chests I appreciate that is
more than I could ever read told of a
numbskull I see IV resk Jessica Thomas
Nolan Anna would have run sanford Mary
Thomas Sanders daughter rourou ken ken
cool Michelle Claus or toxic Sparky X
the weird Minecraft uh
one second sorry I need to get Ned bear
over here cuz he's he's gonna be a
slowpoke about this come on Ned come on
Eddy bar
Ned Matt get over Ned Ned get over here
the weird minecraft DC girl gamer Evan
Armijo John trm historical Bros Quinton
BL Burke Noah Kowalchuk Giancarlo my
name is Jeff top of the morning tea
indeed oh I'm about today
come on Ned Ned Ned boy Ned
god damn it Ned alright fruit roll-up
musical neck Oh kitties rule Christopher
Fuentes Guerra he barred Amanda Leslie
Lenna Oxton seal BMX bricks built
drummer
Maggie sharp Jase Ingram Daniel a mink a
mr. Jun Shelby rainwater rapid cherry
legion Sergio Katie cat Kona Delgado
markiplier flan Voltron V Titan Monique
Drobny kitties rule artful da jr. Dexter
Ian oh my god VIN laser Keith a human
vampy bats 150 I did you don't need to
do that in any capacity don't don't
don't give me any money it's not
necessary at all net is not moving even
remotely santa elena oxen Jamin grandpa
funky seal michaels a night room black
muhammad ali with $50 a marquis mu nu
Katie Katie Smith Mackenzie lover it's
enough there's no need alright I don't
know how to get this guy to move Ned
where did you go
Ned come back you scary bear I don't
even know how I can get them to how can
I get them other areas what how did he
how'd that work all right come on Ned
just please please Ned come on please
I'm begging there we go okay come on Ned
come on Ned debar there we go come on
Ned Ned Ned Ned Ned Ned Ned Ned Ned Ned
come on Ned that's it
damn it Meredith oh my god Ned Ned
please net-net
yes yeah it's please come on Ned I'm
begging you Ned I've got a candy bar
with your name on it
I'll lock turn your bars I know you do
Ned I know you do listen I've got a
banjo we can go out canoeing if you come
down here with me just go and go down
that other corridor we don't have a lot
of time left in the night you gotta come
with me Ned please come on Ned please
I'm begging you Ned how much how much
money do I need to convince you to get
over here Ned Ned goddamn it if you
could just move two inches Ned Ned Ned
please there's not much time left we
only got a minute 30 and it's not DD
ain't even here so like no death ain't
gonna come to us Ned Ned Ned
no Ned come on please Ned baby dead baby
dead baby baby Ned come on Ned Ned you
know you want to get over here Ned
please I'm so bagging you I can't make
it any easier for you Ned I just I'm so
desperately want you to get here I'm
like my arms are oh yeah yeah yeah
that's how you doing Ned that's how you
do it you show me you show me who is the
boughs yeah yeah yeah Ned oh you're Ned
you're so scary you're so scary Ned
you're so scary oh I'm gonna be tearful
I'm gonna be in tears if you killed
there's so much not time left Ned Ned
Ned goddammit Ned Ned please oh my god
Ned it's the soul yes let okay it's yes
yes yeah
stranger danger
oh boy
Ned Ned Ned damn mad you son-of-a-bitch
thank you to all the new sponsors to
Snivy maniac the link dragged mire a
token Taser and everybody giving super -
you don't have to give super - you
really don't ok so that was not the way
to go let's just let's keep going with
trying to do it on 20 mode know what I'm
trying to do is there's a secret voice
line with Ned bear there's a secret
voice line and I want to get it cuz ok
Ned you're just not listening to me Ned
I feel like we're not communicating
properly come on come on man come on it
come on Ned there we go
come on Ned come on you got this Ned you
got it get me get me get me Ned yeah and
it needs a lot of coercion here the
heater make Ned get back that's not the
point of this this is not the point
that's not the point so welcome corrupt
frost thank you so much it's not the
point of what I'm doing here I'm trying
to die from him and he just don't want
to kill me he don't want to I don't know
why I'm perfectly perfectly animatronic
stuffable I'd like to think as much as
any other come on now well that's a new
one but come on Ned you know you know
you want to say the secret line you know
you know you know you want to save this
line Ned I'm on Ned Ned E bar o Neddie
Neddie I'm ready for nanny come on Ned
god damn it Ned if you just please
cooperate okay there we go all right
and oh yeah whoops that's gonna leave a
mark
we're getting there we're getting there
all the duct animatronics besides the
hippo have a secret line I'd say the
hippo that's a complete secret line
anyway but Ned Ned boy Ned Ned Ned Ned
Ned you're gonna get me I'm gonna be so
scared yes yeah it's so fast so fast so
fast Wow
Ned is so strong and so fast I was just
waiting for you to drop your guard oh
thank you doomed friend for becoming
sponsor Abigail gaming
thank you so much Brooke Jackson dr.
sterben and Norwegian pride thank you so
much you get access to some cool custom
emotes and as soon as I can talk to the
YouTube people look I'll have the other
special features for sponsors enabled it
will be soon please come on no no Ned I
love you we're all waiting everybody's
waiting near so so happy and free
a und version I rock nah I'm just trying
to get Ned secret line no Ned come here
no no dad Ned Ned
there we go Ned come on there there we
are come on you guard is Ned Ned Ned the
head come off make me dad Ned
dad come on
hoping it's open for you Ned I'm all Ned
stranger danger god damn it now I'm
gonna you can do it I'm doing fine it's
mad that's not doing what Ned is
supposed to do Ned come on Ned please
say the special it's not gonna be worth
it
it could be worth it I don't know if
there's some other criteria to get this
to happen but it's not even gonna be
worth it come on come on Ned Ned boy
come on you're taking so much time come
on there we go
Lightning McQueen oh thank you guys you
don't need to give me any super chance I
preach I can't even read all of them
this self head Thank You cap off for the
sponsor thank you everybody so much for
the super chance Katie and Lydia nerd I
know it's not I wanted to be better
because there was a there was like
someone gave a $500 super check
yesterday or the other day and I didn't
read it
because I was so tired and sick and I
was just like I felt so bad that I
didn't get to it you guys don't don't
need to do that in any capacity it's
totally fine come on Ned there no just
waiting for you to drop your guard
Mitsy Steigerwald dang it Ned I know Ned
goddamn it Ned everybody just chat Ned
is large and loudly as you can oh come
on please please Ned with any sponsor
has access to the eeo of the emote like
spell Ned with the e is the e come on
Ned you get a good old like this oh god
I can't here we go
yeah wait it didn't do anything
I think it's fine you can only sponsor
on YouTube gaming right now you will be
able to sponsor channel wide soon I just
don't know when that's gonna happen come
on man Ned please good come on come on
no Ned come on dad come on only a one in
a hundred of like chance or something so
obscure like this maybe it maybe it's
something so maybe I should just pull it
up later because it was this I saw this
video of it man come on Ned Ned Ned
keeps killing me yeah yeah yep that is
that is exactly what's happening dad
come on good it's only a few more tries
before we're going after Ned cos Ned as
a secret voice line that I think is
really really really really interesting
no it's not disinformation it may be
disinformation in the way to get it but
it exists I know it exists I'm a hundred
percent positive it exists ahead Ned you
sassy bear come on Ned Ned Ned Ned you
okay dad
Ned listen Ned listen don't you hate
your secondary characters I scream you
scream we all scream for Ned Ned blue is
nah I don't know how rare it is he just
won't do it for fun he's is this fun for
Ned this is what it is dad
I was just waiting for you drop just go
play it I should just go play it I
should just go play I should just die
sure I should just Ned is not gonna
cooperate Thank You red emerald 98
Sparky x4 the sweet sponsors thank you
for all the Congrats on 21 million sorry
didn't have anything I'm still sick I'm
better today Ned would actually
cooperate with me here you feeling so
much better no come on Ned come on you
get here you get here mister come on get
your bare bottom on let's go leave mark
are you saying that cuz my name is that
what he's gonna do Ned is the only man
that is the only animatronic that
matters in this entire game there is no
other animatronic no one else exists no
one else matters it is just me and Ned
Ned and me locked in a cage Ned Ned
Thank You pootis face Erin it's a good
name that bear is the best bear in all
the land there's gonna be worth it guys
it's gonna be worth it listen to me
don't don't click away either cuz we're
part of this together you me and Ned
we're locked to the cage we're all it's
a big cage with tens of thousands of
people in it but it's a big cage but we
all got it Ned is our our friend that's
her friend we're gonna make this work
Thank You oxy pod thank you go to Kings
Island or Cedar Point just go have fun
not not here not here with locked in a
cage with Ned Oh
Ned please please I'm begging you Ned
Ned of everything I've ever known and
everything I've ever done Ned this is
the most important obviously we all know
there's Ned we know this you're so
important to say you're special line
please Ned please Ned Ned
you just got the voice line but I I'm
trying to get the voice line dad please
Ned you're our only hope
your OB Ned Kenobi obi-wan
Ned Obi come on Ned please you're the
last Ned I Ned stranger danger I'm
seeing Ned
all I can see is the color Ned come on
please I'm bagging and no now I'm not
gonna do that
come on come on come on Ned one more
no I like I said I was only gonna do
this like five more times it's like the
tenth time daddy watch this show [ __ ]
bear get up Ned come on Ned
somebody hey don't run from me Ned come
on it's me net boy Ned there are many
ducks Ned boy come on there's only one
duck - Ned - boy
this is how it feels and you get to
experience it over and over and over
again forever I will never let you leave
there was that was it yeah yeah okay so
analysis of that that's two voices at
the same time for those of you who could
hear that that is the secret line yeah
Ned oh hell yeah
Ned boy Ned boy that was a sassy one too
he didn't want to give it to me that
time he was running away but I know I
know yeah that was it that was it so
what he said there was this is how it
feels and you get to experience it over
and over and over again I will never let
you leave I will never let you leave
[Laughter]
feels so creepy and it's like the
background voice a lot of people say
that it sounds like baby but then again
the voice actors for baby does voices
for the other characters too so it could
be literally anything the other thing
I'm gonna do after Ned is this isn't a
secret I think but I've just never dyed
to lefty and I think like the lefty is
such an interesting character in this
whole universe because lefty is like the
animatronic or the marionette is inside
lefty and also the soul of some child
that died outside in the pizzeria
simulator one you guys saw that cutscene
our artful Dodge Junior what was that
yeah that was that was something and
that what that all ties into is there's
this overarching theory about this game
and the overarching theory about is is
this is some kind of purgatory some kind
of Hell for one of the various versions
of purple guy and I don't know who's in
these ones it's Afton and spring-trap
and I'm not sure who's who I'm not the
most knowledgeable about the entire
universe but it's not what what is on
the surface is obvious this is a
purgatory and this is a hell this is a
punishment for someone that line reveals
that this is supposed to be here
for whoever is a part of this entire
existence this is a universe
specifically designed to torture someone
over and over and over and over again it
doesn't make any sense
it's illogical because it's a game but
in the grand scheme of things someone
did something bad whether it's a
nightmare whether it's all a dream like
I I don't really care much about that
what I do care about is what is on the
surface and what is obvious and what
makes the most sense in terms of the
whole reasoning of why and that's like
this is a punishment and and like this
character here lefty who I've never
really died to before because I was
always good about the temperature but
I'm gonna let's try to make as much
noise as possible bang clang let's get
the heat up in here of this [ __ ] let's
make a toaster let's do it come on aah
clang clang everybody get your pots and
pans out boom bang oh gosh I'm slamming
doors like you wouldn't believe
turn the fan on cold near was it God
turn the fan on [ __ ] sorry
gonna be some [ __ ] about this huh
you're gonna be a little you know be
like Ned you don't be like Ned Lefty not
left
can you not do anything here I'm gonna
run out of power
damn you suck so much just get your butt
out here Lefty
don't be a net get out here Lefty no not
you
lefty the doors don't count in noise oh
you you've got to be [ __ ] me there's
no way me slamming the doors now don't
know oh my god let me just please I'm
begging you love dude how can I make
more noise I can't I can't
lefty please just I'm right here I know
it doesn't make any more noise but it
feels good lefty can you just love doing
this is the only noise I can make now
loved a bird it know I lost it okay
don't make me sit here in the darkness
first
damn you Lefty I'm in the darkness lefty
I can't see but I know you're there what
day you left me behind
you [ __ ] damn it bird kill me please
give me one percent power where are you
bird damn it who's reaching in the
darkness for a bird that's not there
left left
Thank You Gabe's channel gif baked
Darlene Roberts is fr Thomas Aqil
Carissa Bowers Garrett at boot a NAT
Caitlyn ween brave shark 200 taller
super - you don't need to oh my gosh
Margaret please knows me I've been a
stuff around three years well of
thank you so much brave shark I
appreciate that but you don't need to
thank you Rachel Mary for the sponsor
rashim Reshiram dude pika Fighter Master
gaming autofill the signless one and
sorry to everybody that I can't read oh
my god I'm gonna Lefty
you son of a tit come on dude lefty
lefty how can I gotta get like help me
out here just to start Blair in an
airhorn I mean just to make Lefty more
goddamn agitated because I'm not gonna
make it more agitating now there's
nothing to make it more agitated Lefty
you shut up dick lefty Lefty
I'm grabbing you by the throat and I'm
shaking you lefty just be annoyed at me
I'm just a loud douchebag come on Lefty
please how can I didn't there's this
stupid lefty you sack of [ __ ] I'm gonna
win from this you got like 200 points
great the [ __ ] come on Lefty you sack
of [ __ ] you piece of garbage
lefty what the [ __ ] do you think this
game is canon I mean it just what do you
think what like what matters if
something's canon or not if everything
in the entire game Sears was canon that
the story would be so clogged that it
wouldn't make any sense a lot of like a
lot of what mr. hippo said is actually
the wisest thing in this entire game
people read too much into details about
everything to people dive too deep if
you try to pick apart every word in the
story you're gonna lose your mind
it's like going after things that are
like not supposed to be gone after it's
like yeah you can good 5020 mode I bet
if you find them right exploit if you
have to do the right thing I bet it
could be possible but like that's not
the point of it the point of this game
is to have fun with it and like to
explore like well what it all really
needs so we're gonna bring help you in
here just to help us get some bang bang
and noise in here huh Frick man use
phone guy from all phone guy yeah I got
a I forgot well I got help in here
where's help me help me help me help you
come on help me
[Music]
it's like impossible to die from lefty
I've never died from lefty before and I
think it's because it's a seemingly
difficult to not the Qi wanted burden
thank you for being late goddamn healthy
doctor Olympic Lefty please I am trying
I am legitimately trying come on I'm I'm
trying so hard is lefty police I am
trying so hard stop bullying Lefty Akira
Akiyama I'm not bullying lefty how is
this not working
how is this not working Meaghan as you
toasty in here for you lefty please
Thank You Ashley barrage this for the
new turn on global music by I don't want
it sue them I don't want to sue them I
want to make them pissed I wanna piss
them off don't they left that order
doctor doesn't let the final
[Music]
it's impossible to detail it's
impossible there's no way it's
impossible it's impossible to die from
lefty it's just chicken impossible you
can't I can't do it he won't do nothing
about it
he's dying there's nothing to die no die
I didn't please how does anybody die
from this monstrosity believe this this
should be impossible it's so hard it's
so loud music man would have killed me
ages ago
please don't look at him oh if I look at
him does that make a difference just
looking at him make a difference I won't
look it's like a watch pot you can't
boil it Lefty won't boil if you can't
watch him make sense but then help he
doesn't I'll flip the chemistry oh that
wasn't a lot that wasn't if I turn on
the fan it's gonna get cooler he gets
out too damn hot okay
so what's what's fascinating about lefty
is his lines her her lines are super
creepy because it's all just going
there's ramen here from both of us and
it's at what it's suggesting is like in
pizzeria simulator there was a moment
where like the the the marionette that
was there maybe not this one but one of
the marionettes was supposed to watch
the children there and then when lefty
went or when this little girl got
outside she was killed or died from
exposure of the elements and then the
marionette went out there looking for
her and then kind of like kind of like
merged consciousness with this child and
like that's how that happened but I'm
not 100% sure where that ties into the
whole lore but what's fascinating about
is leftie itself lefty is an acronym
lefty is an acronym for a very specific
type of animatronic and what was it
lefty lefty lefty lefty lefty lefty
lefty lefty I look at the wiki a lot
yeah okay lefty is an acronym that
stands for lure encapsulate fuse
transport extract that's what lefty
means and what's so fascinating about
that is that means someone designed
lefty the amat Roenick to go out there
and capture something not just capture
encapsulate and then fuse fuse is such a
bizarre word to to suggest something
it's just like well these are the
fascinating piece of lore that I like
about this universe like these
animatronics are more than just
animatronics they are husks they're
husks that are designed to encapsulate
Souls like the whole concept of these
being fun animatronics for you know
children to enjoy like you can see it as
some kind of fever dream for the creator
of and whoever moves that whichever
Afton was the original creator of these
things whether it's this afternoon or
whatnot like he made these things on
such a different level than anything
else that you could possibly see in
terms of the physical animatronic world
he
went to this incredible length to make
this happen and and when you get down to
the idea of these animatronics combined
with the the idea of the endoskeleton
stand the idea that these endoskeletons
like in the funtime world were these
we're driving masses of metal muscle
like that just moved around especially
when it comes down to Eddard
and like looking at at that compared to
the other alike endoskeletons that are
in here and stuff like that these weird
and uh skeletons that just wear these
the these outfits of other things so
boil away all of the the outer
appearances of any of these things you
get down to these these two different
types of animatronic endoskeletons the
basic ones and then the metal wormy ones
and then you get down to the element of
if a human's in there like the
animatronic suit itself is a
encapsulation for these souls of people
and also the spirits of the animatronics
themselves and it's so it gets into this
weird world where I think like these
these endoskeletons that are the basic
functions these are just robots like
stuff like that and these didn't come to
life at all until people like got trash
stuffed inside and because the real
weirdness was in the the masks
themselves and like not necessarily
Enniskillen so then you get into the
endoskeleton that we're in the funtime
world where they're these weird wormy
things that think on their own and like
they exist on their own and they they
arrive on their own and when this these
things went inside the purple guy or the
guy that was going to become the purple
guy after the scooping room scooped him
out like it just it's bizarre bizarre
world where the purple guy ends up being
this husk like these these outfits are
and so the purple guy ends up being
something that could be like encapsulate
other souls and maybe that's what's the
debt like the desire of it and and so
it's this weird weird world where like
there's a lotta different ways but it
boils down to this thing where these
suits can hold souls and I think that's
a fascinating thing so someone said that
these other characters had a voice lines
to them let me let me just look at that
up to confirm because I'm not I'm not
gonna chase after him if there was
something else yeah I'm feeling a little
better I'm still sick like I'm still
sick and for everybody that's just
joining us here thank you so much for
being here thank you for all the super
dressed thank for all this stuff like
that we're exploring secrets we're not
trying
50 20 I'm still not doing 50 20 mode but
I also wanted to clear up some things a
lot of people said that I was not
enjoying enjoying uh like this game this
game is actually my favorite of all the
kustanai --ts this is my favorite I
think it's so well done I think it's
really cool the way you can try your own
methodology so I'm I'm going to be oh
yeah she does okay
happy frog does let me just confirm that
the other ones in Pig patch let's go pig
pet pig patch okay
happy frog is a secret line pig patch do
you have a secret line
no doesn't look like but it looks like
yeah it looks like happy frog does let
me look up Orville good old oil Orville
elephant let's see ah Orville does okay
so let's go with happy frog first and
see where we go from there okay
listen okay all right you piece of [ __ ]
I'm already gonna start off this with it
by calling you a piece of [ __ ] okay look
you I don't think you've ever gotten to
kill me that's fine
net has you have I get that pig pad
hasn't but you know we're gonna ignore
that cuz I don't care you never had a
chance the audio wheeler works super
perfect for you Orville I'll get to you
you've killed me before but look listen
happy frog we can get along we can be
friends we can be nice to each other we
can use me you and me we could be
friends we can be pals if you don't come
but be realistic okay all right listen
happy fur we on the same page here
mmm-hmm I may be in hell but it's not
like I'm trapped in here with you you're
trapped in here with me okay be nice no
I'm not gonna do 5020 mode listen I'm
not I'm not just not but listen oh oh oh
oh oh happy frog you are you you make me
oh you make me so happy happy frog oh
you are froggy baby don't like your
voice already alright okay alright happy
frog happy Pappy can I call you HAP can
I call you frog can I cook h-f you don't
have many good nicknames can I call you
hoppy
hippos amphibio can I could happy frog
this is not it doesn't roll off the
tongue very well can I like Ned Ned Ned
was a real nice easy named Ned you know
Ned your dad Ned's gonna dead yeah yeah
okay alright yeah
oh that's yeah that's what I was like
okay
like you I'm feeling alright I'm fine
I'm still sick but I'm fine don't worry
about me champ Fable thank you for this
sweet sweet sponsor and yes you get
access to emotes and more features
coming soon come on hippity-hoppity
hippity-hoppity over here happy Pappy
LAPI slippy oh god I hate you I hate you
sloppy I hate you Sloopy look Slurpee
all right listen up sloppy we you you
need to just shut up until you get your
good line so just slumpy can you just
hippity hop over here
slappy come on listen just don't talk
I'll take mr. hippo home for you he ever
just hear someone's voice that is just
so unbelievably annoying that you just
want to tear your own eyes out you ever
hear a voice like that that's kind of
like what Slurpees a voice here is nope
not listen slump oh you just don't even
bother don't even bother I hope that
your special line is not in the same
voice that you're delivering all the
other lines I'm sorry this is insulting
to the voice actress at this point I I
don't know I don't want to be mean about
this but I'm gonna be mean about this
listen slump oh here she sounds like
nope nope hippity-hoppity slippity-slop
buddy get over
sounds like charm EB sounds like
Harlequin no not necessarily it depends
on which Harlequin you're thinking of
yeah no I I don't want to be in soldiers
which advertisers did an amazing job at
having an overly cutesy annoying or
borderline a psychopathic annoying voice
like the thing is like it's just the way
the voice goes up all the time like you
and get that duck it matches any much is
usually it's like it's just I gave up on
fifty twenty mode still I'm not gonna be
that like there's no way oh gosh Thank
You Alana kid kilo doll Smith for the
sponsor sandwich guy nefarious Lenny
lopoliths hey Mark its Lenny again can
you shout I can my friends olara and
faye get a shout out well hi suppose
they just did elites Ward man five just
Bennett's up four five years ago on to
say thank you for being amazing valid or
not some entertainment show you yeah I
wonder why
all right Thank You Nathaniel Steve Zack
for the sponsor Nathan Hoffman and a
girl thank you so much all right come on
no no no no listen listen slump oh come
here
sloppy slump oh come over here come on
flippity floppity oh [ __ ] what up sloppy
slipper oh thank you car Nick this 23
for the sweet sponsor we got this we got
this
don't be an ED oh good new oh it's green
looks lip Oh Sabo celebrity new app oh
come on down come on lippy you know you
want to
rockstar bonnie is mark I don't know
about that Amir Ofer come on come on
slippy slippy Samba slippy samba come on
slippy there we go come on o resistant
maybe this is gonna be the one happy
frog does happy frog does if I don't get
it in like five I'm just gonna play it
from the website happy frog does happy
frog does I no no I got it
happy frog does I know trust me you
trust me listen listen to me would I
ever like listen would I ever lie to you
no the answer is no I would not don't
pretend like I would never
it's true pigpig patch has your favorite
line uh what I'll do is actually what I
should do is I just I should get both of
them in there may be but doraville is
not bothered by the Laura
Oh God getting Orville to kill me is
gonna be a pain in the ass Oh No
come on come on here we go come on no no
come on come on here we go come on oh
come here
I'll marry you however here we go oh I
swear I swear I swear guys please listen
to me even though it's just like 30
minutes to get the first one to go
listen it's gonna be so worth it you're
gonna be like wow and I'm gonna be like
told you and you're gonna be like no we
shoulda listened to you Morgan I'm gonna
be like I know I keep telling you guys
and you don't know but you know that's
fine whatever
and then you guys are gonna be like God
but next time I promise I will and then
you guys
I'm gonna be like okay and then you guys
are gonna be like just wine
guys I think this is not a life I swear
ass it's said on the website there was
it said tried to drag both of them I
don't think Orville is trying to buy the
audio lord I don't think he's in any way
affected Orville you want to play nice
no okay happy frog happy happy happy
thoughts happy thoughts for a happy frog
Thank You Amanda Mitchell for the sweet
new sponsor Ian Alexander for the sweet
sponsored super hot dog hey Mark I've
been watching your West of loathing
series and I've been laughing my butt
off that was such a good series there's
another one that I didn't finish but
only because I did get the ending and I
thought there was gonna be like a secret
ending but apparently there wasn't so I
was just like yeah it's all right I mean
I had a great time with that game I had
so much it's there no I'm not going in a
downward spiral of happy frogs I'm
perfectly sane this is the best thing to
do when I'm sick this is the greatest
thing that I could possibly do please
frog I'm a frog
okay simply a derogatory term now I'm
just saying it's so much you frog come
are you are you getting the vent
I'm gonna try with I'm gonna try okay
we're gonna do this this is gonna be a
exercise in hell but we're gonna do this
on level one just in case like it's a
[Music]
slippery slope pop booty dude a sleepy
frog what am I even doing if it didn't
work for if it didn't work for Ned why
would I work for happy why did I do this
I didn't need Oh bird I don't care what
I didn't need to do this thank you James
lefeber over musical pumpkin Thebes
chard burden Austin James Cammie Komori
Mary Jo's oh my god okay I'm just gonna
hear you whatever you feel like you come
back whenever you feel like listen
listen I'm not gonna criticize you you
don't criticize me oh thank you to msn
Nikki Lee oh I'm about to pass out here
okay good good
you've made such a huge impact on my
life thank you for saving my life many
times oh thank you for watching and I'm
sure that all that was done through your
own will and I if I played any part of
that thank you but I think that was all
you so I see Thank You Steph vermillion
goddammit lefty yeah indeed Durer
werewolf 93 let me smash please I don't
think you wanted man
this frog here is probably not the best
thing and thank you everybody else
that's been giving super chance and
whatnot and new sponsors I will have
something for the sponsors real soon
thank you in Talia for a new sponsor and
just thank you everybody for being here
come on please I'm gonna run out of
power I'm gonna run out power please
please
slippy your sort so gosh darn close look
it's a I'm checking the website while
I'm doing this it says all the website
if I don't get it from this I'm just
gonna play the other follow no I'm
that's cheap to do they're gone Thank
You Jessica
McCann me you know Javik come on market
poo you can do it oh there we go come on
one more
just a hippity-hop just a slippity-slop
just a slew bitty whoop there's this
little bitty poop poop poop poop out the
duct to poop yourself Sloopy poop come
on please
Gregor be dragon I definitely got more
entertainment out of you these days than
most Triple A games I play these days so
I might as well play the price of
admission get well soon oh thank you for
the $50 super chat I mean I don't know
about that justification of it but if
you if I'm able to entertain you in
every way
mark is never not sick I am actually not
sick a lot of the year but I get sick
like three times a year and that may
seem like a lot but it is a lot is this
cuz I travel so much and I meet so many
people this is like and in like any
moment that I lose sleep it's whenever I
lose sleep my immune system tanks and
then I just get sick I know I'm do I can
go to conventions and so long as I get
like good sleep I'll be fine fluffy
co-op come on
thank you the Cheshire Cat also you get
special if you've been sponsored for a
long time up to two years I've made
special loyalty badges for them they're
all variations of the the markiplier
heart so that's that's pretty cool
but like there's only been like two
people that are even at the one month
mark so it'll be like I will not give
the frog I know Oliver thank you so much
starless shine how many words can you
say I think in ten seconds okay here I
go
[Music]
okay got it okay I thought of a lot a
lot I wasn't counting was I supposed to
count I don't no idea 300 rounded words
I'm gonna say 300 words I thought of it
Diego and carne a CEO thank you so much
I love you do keep it up I will try if I
can just get this gosh I already got
lefty lefty doesn't have a secret line I
just wanted to play a lefty line cuz it
fascinated me alright go go frog Rock
I'm gonna get this eventually it took it
took a long time if I don't get it in
five more tries I'm gonna do this count
them down for me this is the fifth try
if I don't get it in five more tries I'm
just gonna play from the website because
I'm not always forever doing this I
might waste forever doing this frog
where where are you frog there you are
hello you disappeared oh so scared
alright come on Emma
gotta Canada Canada
no I'm not gonna play them that's
cheating that's cheating it's cheating
it's cheating
Lauren Creek thanks for sponsoring a
chipster three-to-one this is for
helping me smile during the aftermath of
my brother's suicide you deserve it you
helped so many and you don't even know
it feel better
happy 21 million I'll keep doing this
until you see it I swear oh my gosh I'm
sorry that you you were doing super
chesa I didn't see it I'm so sorry to
hear about your brother
and I'm glad that my videos were able to
help in any way but it's it's tough
times I'm so sorry the elephant no you
know you're not presenting alternative
options here just because you give
another animal that you suggest to you
if I don't think that's a good I don't
think that's the best way to go about
this yeah yeah but you know you do you
with your super chats you do you do you
with whatever you done Erica Kendrick
shout out my son Dylan loves math oh hey
Dylan yeah we're gonna give this gonna
get this soon what was the number of it
three for three there's three whatever I
don't even remember this is probably - I
think this is two more
uh the lastest giant mark my butter
daughter will be born in October please
shout Reina so I can show her this video
when she's older please Oh
Reina and all congratulations on the new
baby well whenever the baby finally
decides to show up all they use Omar's
this so sweet that's ridiculously sweet
thank you yeah all right one more hang
on no hang on I know that I said that
was the last one but one more here we go
one more one more one more hang on
everybody this is gonna be so worth it
you're gonna be like wow that's exactly
what you're gonna say you're gonna be
yeah alright one more one more you guys
are gonna one one more here we go one
more this is I this is gonna be the last
one I promise it's gonna be the last one
Thank You Al Andreas for the new sponsor
men you know Oh one three thank you so
much spot you you can sponsor through
YouTube gaming but there's gonna be
another way soon and there's gonna be
more features for sponsors soon it just
really is really cool because we've done
some cool community features that are
coming out one more one more guys I know
this next one's gonna be the one I'm
like a gambler in Vegas no next one's
gonna be the jackpot but the jackpot is
a frog screaming in my face exactly what
I want out of Vegas plays I keep
throwing my money like this to Cirque de
Soleil all I really want is a frog
please one more come on this is gonna be
the one big big baby bump and frog come
on Sloopy slippy come on and slip your
way into my heart
please I'm so desperate as this
punishment for me and my brother
accidentally diverting the creek and
killing all those frog eggs when we were
kids we didn't mean to we didn't know we
were kids we didn't think it was gonna
do it we're just moves on the rocks
we're sorry Thank You Jessie Wesley
thank you for everything you do love
from the UK well thank you so much for
that and thanks for being a sponsor as
well my Kela Fisher thank you so much
and this is gonna be the really me and
my brother we would go out into the
woods a lot and so we we would do things
like divert the creek we'd cut vines and
and we ended up accidentally diverting
the river and we didn't realize that the
other side of the river Creek it was not
a river it's a creek it's like this wide
like it's not a river but it pulled into
this pool of water that just so happened
to have frog eggs in it and we didn't
realize that so we ended up accidentally
killing a whole batch of frog eggs and
bullfrog eggs it's big a big top for
offenders not good and felt bad and then
oh then we did something even worse
because we scooped up some of the
tadpoles in a in a giant pickle jar you
know those big giant pickle jars and we
brought it back to the house but you
know we didn't realize how like water
circulation worked you know filtration
systems we didn't really get the concept
so we ended up though we stuffed like
the jar full of tadpoles and they died
so fast and we're just like oh my god
we're just where does the absolute worst
human beings that could ever exist in
the history of forever and this is gonna
happen everybody all the under your
horses I telling my horrible childhood
story of how i'ma basically was a child
eco-terrorist
and I just thank you the flame word
thank you jizz Aleta antunez music chick
one two one two three Enzo gaming
Jericho the god x kc tech sada eli lewis
thank you so much okay it has to be in a
different room
different room I'm a double in whoa what
room
what room what room can I been oh you
mean the office Oh would that matter did
that it didn't work when we I'm dying
here Oh No Oh God everybody pity me I'm
so sick I'm trying
happy frog it was there no no it's this
is the thing it's the Saints is rare
it's just rare it's just I got it it's
just rare it's worth it it's about the
journey not the destination
just because this journey sucks to me
it's about the really shitty journey
it's about the horrible no water stuffed
in a car with seven brothers and sisters
it says it's his horrible cross-country
journey to go to Disneyland and who
cares if the destination is Disneyland
that's about that shitty sweaty journey
where you have to take a bathroom break
every two seconds but dad doesn't want
to pull over so you got to pee in the
bottle again and it's like I don't wanna
pee in the bottle but it's about the
journey it's about the journey it's not
about the bottle and I mean the bottle
is part of the journey you peeing in the
bottle is part of the journey
and then your brother tries to hold you
out the window cuz you don't want to pee
in the bottle anymore and so you're on
this journey everyone can see you peeing
out the window and you don't know any
better because they're six and you're
stuffed in the middle seat on the hump
and nobody it's not about Disneyland's
about the journey peanut I know that's
what it's about
who cares about Disneyland I bet there's
animatronics at Disneyland oh don't pay
out the window but who cares
the Frog waiting for me Disneyland
that's what I care about cuz I'm sixteen
I'll do I know on a journey with my
seven brothers and sisters and goddamnit
dad there's a rest stop right there we
could pull over any time and no I gotta
pee in the bottle again I don't even
know anymore what are you saying I don't
even remember it's about the journey
that's it it's about the journey it's
about the journey to let that journey
happen just journey is about the band
Journey okay here we go
I think I was in a different office that
time Lutra know how much more I don't
know it's gonna happen it happens I know
it's got there's got to be something
that happens here it's about the journey
and then I got to do war ville elephant
just play the line I couldn't play
though I could do it I could do it I'm
trying to get a special line from this
frog the frog has a special lion and I
want to get it's not even that special
it's not that special oh look this is
the kind of frustration I try to avoid
in these games this is y55 mode was so
satisfying for me because it's like
God's just if I mess up it's be messing
up
that was it that was it yeah yeah see
it's the same thing and it's the same
voice behind the line it's the same
voice it's the same voice it's the same
voice behind the line
that's what's so fascinating about it is
it's not just it's not just the frog
being suddenly creepy what was the
specific line I don't know that one as
well as the net one I like the net one
better we've only just begun I will
never let you leave I will never let you
rest with the same voice the the baby
sounding whisper voice whoever did that
I don't know if it's baby specifically
but someone behind the voice is out for
vengeance if there's vengeance that's
the whole crux of this whole story it's
revenge it's revenge about someone being
wronged and I think like it all boils
down to the same thing no matter how
many different variations of it there
are like these are all the same
characters they're just different
variations of it different envisioning
of it like four different perspectives
of the exact same character and I think
I think like that's the point like it
doesn't matter who it is specifically at
its core at its deepest layer it's about
the same story revenge for these kids
who were murdered like that's the crust
but the bite the bite is like that's
something that a lot of people focus on
the bite the bite the bite put the bite
and I think people forget like the the
whole core of this story is that like in
the first game like in the in the
message and on the walls these kids were
murdered murdered kids murdered kids the
bite does play a very important feature
of it I know but like at the core of it
it's murder
it's murder it's screaming bloody murder
at the top of your lungs it's the souls
of these kids possessing these
animatronics and whatever like the way
that they're made in some fantastical
way to be horrible soul encapsulated
like you're looking to much of the
details the the crux of the story is
these because we're murdered and they
have a chance at revenge why are they so
intent on killing the person playing the
game they're so intent on it no matter
what situation no matter what happens
they want to kill
very specifically they want to kill
number one they killed the phone guy and
number two they they try their damnedest
to kill you the player like that's what
matters everything else is just
ancillary details you can dig through
the details forever and ever but what
matters is that like this is a story of
revenge this ultimate customer is the
culmination of that revenge this
personalized hell from every nightmare
of your entire existence of your entire
life and all these demons chasing you
culminating in one big environment
that's just trying to kill you because
you wronged them and they're not gonna
let you die they're not gonna let you
die either just like them you don't get
to die you exist in this tormented hell
forever and that's the point of it like
that's the point doesn't matter like
this 50 different characters in here are
six different characters or shadow
versions of whatever like that's digging
too deep you do it if you want I don't
care do it if you want but this this
this
that's what matters okay now the
elephant because that would be even ours
let me just play the elephant line
Orvil because I mean III don't think
Orville's is uh ya can't not fooled by
the audio lurk
early it's not very often okay this is
the line he tried to release you he
tried to release us but I'm not gonna
let that happen I will hold you here I
will keep you here no matter how many
times they burn us right so what this
line is I hadn't actually read this one
I didn't even know this one let me play
one more time he tried to release you he
tried to release us but I'm not gonna
let that happen I will hold you here I
will keep you here no matter how many
times they burn us okay so what he's
talking about there what he's talking
about there is the the culmination of
pizza reassembling later
in all of pizzaria simulator what's
what's going on is this guy is narrating
the player who has guided through this
job interview for studying these
animatronics the whole point of it is to
get these animatronics
in a building burn them so that they can
free the souls he tried to release you
specifically the player of the game he
tried to release us get the souls of the
children out of the these monstrous
bodies in this one it was molten freddy
scrap baby Afton and forget who else
there was some other people there but I
don't even remember but the whole point
is like he tried to release it whoever
he is I don't know I'm not too deep into
it but he tried to lose you and us but
these animatronics don't want you to
escape your fate
they are like just in it in a whole
different hell of their own and they
just want you to suffer like and and
probably rightfully so I'm not big on
revenge but like rightfully so these
kids suddenly are given this new hell of
a second life in these in these bodies
and it's just like this horrible
horrible existence from from the creator
of these things probably he released us
is referring to the creators of these
things who knows how this all works but
in him doing that like he's uh he's kind
of like trying to end it all but these
these animatronics is don't want it to
be ended so you end up with this
never-ending cycle that exists in this
world where you're just in hell and you
lived through hell over and over and
over and over and over again makes sense
right alright so what am I do now is I'm
going to try to get I don't know I don't
know if it's every 700 or every 4000
points let me look at that up cutscenes
I just want to get a few more cutscenes
I don't know how many more I'm gonna get
because if it gets to like hard to get
through them and I'm not gonna worry
about it
um baba - Baba - Bob yeah no is it
everywhere every 700 or every uh
thousand I'm just gonna go for 4,500 and
see if that does something if that does
something then that's good if it doesn't
do something then oh well you know what
that's whatever our fun time chica you
go up lefty apparently you never even
bother me so whatever
after your fine scrap baby you're I'm
gonna do you a 10 but okay Bolton
Freddie you're fine
this guy's fine music man is probably
fine but I'm gonna skip over for now
fund em chica I'm gonna skip over that
for now I'm good at getting the guitar
so I'll do that Rockstar Freddie I know
how to beat you I'm gonna keep you all
at ten just because I don't want to not
to be too inundated with you guys you're
good you're good you're good you guys
are good but I don't remember how bad
you are at little twenty so I'm gonna
keep them at ten you're good I'm gonna
keep the office cool you're good I can
get the coins I'm marrying that I'm
gonna keep you at just a five because
with you you two you're good you're good
plushies are good
Melora I'm keeping you on five fund on
foxy you're good I'm probably undeath
coin u + e good oh wait no I need 20
coins if I'm gonna get them let's keep
those guys at a ten cuz I can get the
coins under someone to get all the coins
what was another one this one so I'm
just trying to get I'm just trying to
get forty five hundred which oh these
guys are good I can definitely take care
of these guys pretty easily you're good
along with you you two are good oh
that's too many points [ __ ]
then let's make it a little I only want
forty five hundred so let's remove well
if we can remove you that a little
easier keep you down I guess I mean
you're fine but whatever I only want to
get forty five hundred because I don't
want to do too many your free points so
actually yeah I should have gotten all
the free ones these guys I can take care
of no problem
well I guess I'll just keep these guys
these guys are the ones that just stick
like glue
yeah that's too many points I don't want
that many points alright okay you guys
out here I guess
yeah like it's so many pull why do I
have so many points I don't want that
many points duh
I don't want this many points as too
many points I don't need this many
points how do i do why do I have so many
points alright the lorry you're out I
guess go away you going
oh no you're fine I'm good with you
let's get you out of there how do you
look so easy to get points alright the
plushy animatronics I guess I don't have
to get them all I just want forty five
hundred that's that's all I want
okay 4750 that's all the that's all -
Garrett that's is easy fun time foxy is
the only one that matters and I could
take you out of there okay easy enough
that'll do if I get four there we go
alright so the only ones I got to worry
about is literally nobody haften
Rockstar Bonnie that's it alright well
that's easy enough
okay let's do this I just want to see if
4500 it's a make it 4600 is that what it
is I just want to see I just want to see
if 4500 cuz it's like if it's every 700
I'll do 4500 and then I'll do weight is
that is that even a multiple I can't
even remember if that's a multiple I
can't remember what was I doing there
who's in here I don't even remember
who's in here who's in here who's in
here okay I cannot remember who's in
here
who the hell is in here you're not in
here oh that's right okay there's got to
be easy then there's literally nobody
here that matters I'm so rusty at this
I'm trying to I'm trying to like think
as if I'm going to have all these
amazing characters here and I'm just
kind of easy all right
okay easy enough
all right thank you to miss galactic for
the sweet new sponsor that one lousy
gamer thank you so much if there's no
one else here yeah it's a little
multitasking that's it
I mean it's got to wait like a few
minutes yeah thank you summit for cactus
syrup angel of love milites San Morales
ssj and yeah they yeah they can't get
past the audio more oh golden Freddy
also three points I see that let's cool
it down in here almost forgot about
afternoon oops did I not get that old
man consequences Oh doesn't matter I
can't keep the fan on for all up let's
actually do that cuz then I don't even
have to think about anything
Oh rock star Bonnie that's right okay
easy enough not hard Thank You amber
lemons camcorder Dre 2 2 4 - Dustin neon
Olivia Ashman what i'm doing here is i'm
doing the point climb for cutscenes
that's all I'm doing
[Music]
easy-peasy I thought fun time foxy was
here did I take funtime socks yeah
goddamnit okay well that's gonna be a
problem um well uh listen bonnie bonnie
bonnie baby bonnie baby
bonnie baby ah bonnie baby don't ya okay
Bonnie baby all right Bonnie baby
hey hey friend that's just instinct at
this point yeah thank you oof can you
give Alan a shout out in the ER Alan's
working in the ER ah kudos to the Alan
that's tough job originally that's what
I wanted to do I was uh I was actually
going to biomedical engineering school
to go into Medical School oddly enough
which was a weird way to go about
medical school like definitely not the
way I'd recommend anybody if you're
going if you're looking into going to
medical school don't don't bother with
don't bother with trying to do it
through biomedical engineering that is
literally the hardest path that you
could possibly do yeah I'm still not
going for 5020 mode no I I personally I
don't want to waste some time on this is
actually going to be the last episode
that I do of five nights at Freddy's
ultimate custom night just because for
me personally uh I'd like I'd like the
challenge of it 55 mode was very
difficult I spent probably close to
close to like
probably list of 15 hours 15 hours
getting into 55 it was very difficult it
was a really ridiculously difficult
thing and it was a good child for me I
had a ton of fun doing it
[Music]
Wow yeah I had a great time
a lot of people think I didn't know I
was having a great time when I was
playing those game modes all right that
do anything oh it did
Wow it did whoa whoa - Yahoo a
legitimate area Samus you start a
fatality
what has your sorry wha
Junu is Shiva but as you know canonicus
Karenina
jakotsu etosha sarcophagus NCD re you
children stood you're one of a kind of
material what did you do this time
oh my god a cute tattoos Teemo so
steve-o - Oreo move a little so ratio I
gotta say not you
Yannick a banana Jesus - yah - casino
Koneru nahuel boy thee take your flute
let's say your flute yeah okay cut it at
door a woman
stupid
I know it's saying something different
in Japanese it's the same Japanese every
single time I think every single time is
the same Japanese it's just wear a hat
what you know what's fascinating about
this is like people who are
theorycrafting these particular like
stories and stuff they're gonna be
digging into this like what does it mean
what does it all mean what is the
connection to the fruit hat is the fruit
hat in reference to the child's souls
like they're gonna be just like
completely picking it apart and the
thing goes hilarious yeah just get left
yep cuz you know who cares I mean left
he didn't even bother me from anything
that I was doing before and you know
what actually just in case I don't want
that to ruin like a late night one
who else wait what are they easy golden
Freddy yeah gold pretty easy can do um a
blip blip oh we did boo-boo bumble bee
bumble who's who's he free music man I
was kind of noisy I just but mostly just
cuz I was kind of lazy I could do foxy I
guess who's it there's gotta be one
that's free right
just like the easy ZZ no have I gotten
all the free ones probably probably okay
let's just do now I'll forget I'll
forget the time I know I will
there's knowing me I absolutely will
withered Bonnie wouldn't be to the toy
the toy guys wouldn't be so bad I can
just keep them out of ten and they're
not gonna like be super bothering me so
that's not too bad then I could do you
at a ten like I'm pretty good at seeing
that and well let's try 5100 because I
know it's 60-49 it would be the next
increment but I just want to go for an
even want to go for an even 5,000 so
let's actually taking you out of there
and let's just you know five thousand
see if that gets me another one so the
only other added is withered Bonnie and
the toys and golden Freddy but I was
doing that anyway okay let's do this I'm
not gonna turn off the fan cuz I'm a
rebel like that that's a lot of wow
that's a lot on that's a lot of ruckus
down here I don't appreciate that
well said I have to worry about oh you I
remember you piece of [ __ ] I
accidentally put it up I'm pretty sure
that so that's what the problem was I
don't know I just put it up
instinctively yeah I beat 55 mode in the
last one I'm not going for fifty twenty
mode because I'm lame lightweight
because I'm lame like that flippy-floppy
you son of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] I can't believe you
can't believe you've done this why am i
doing that don't need to do that either
oh yeah rock star is it easy
yeah I can't believe I had such a what
no I I can't believe I had such a tough
time climbing the point letter of the
percent but like now that I've learned
like the very basic stuff that I've
learned in 50 in 55 mode I've actually
learned a lot of really good skills that
helped out with what I'm doing here
because even if DD adds somebody I think
I'd be okay where you go we got luan huh
we go ahead huh oops my bad weird huh
what you look cute cute little
Willamette romo un but you God I keep
forgetting that you're there oh I'm just
gonna blindly click wherever the guitar
might be no did I get it I didn't get it
where was that
ah [ __ ] tit you who'd you ask what did
you add who'd you add hold it up
ah [ __ ] god damn it hello
I don't see who they added must wait
unless spring plush ah come on I got I
got curved puzzled there
that was my bad does so stupid all right
I got it I got I got I got did not that
didn't happen it didn't happen you guys
didn't see nothing
whoa you almost got slipped by let's
push you back just a bit rock star
I don't know if it's up or down or not
I've completely forgot
god damn you if you don't if you don't
let me get my goddamn guitar Oh
toasting god damn it every time I pull
up the monitor
I saw you and nerd here come the end
there's the boy oh there's that almost
forgot about you actually don't even
need to go into the monitor like at all
I could I could do this without that but
I like a challenge it's kind of fun what
I really could just sit here the whole
time probably
yeah all right thank you thank you
gesture jingles thank you Sean Lyons
harder Kathy
Thank You Luca Kieran gerd versus facts
thank you all so much literally opening
the camera at this point would be
detrimental to what I'm trying to do
totally do but I'm so bored I'm so bored
it's so boring
the squeaky squonk II Marriott and nerd
Dubai hello boring and boring as the
boring a boring and very boring boring
boring boring and nobody moving the duck
toes all right this is easy one okay
thank you to vampy bats brandon gill
jester jingles there's so much to keep
track of how do you do it it's it's just
practice that's right
oh my god yeah I hate it when that ad
pops up right when I flip though it's
like it does it intentionally right when
I flipped the camera off there's an ad
and that's annoying it's just like it's
like I was saying in the last episode
when I was doing this before it's
instinct you you get you get good at the
game just by looking at it and repeating
there's so many different variables here
but it's really it's not that bad once
you get it because there's only so much
that can happen to you at once that
there's there's a physical limit how
much can happen to you at once and it's
just about juggling
was it
[Music]
okay here we go
I don't know if there's gonna be a new
cutscene after this I might have to jump
up to because I got it at 4500 but I
don't know if this is gonna get a
cutscene because people were saying that
it was every 700 oh I guess it is so
that must have been the 4,800 teen boy
this is gonna bounce between these two
the whole time I know that but I don't
think it was meant to last from my heart
belongs to another he's so amazing and
strong so so cute and I think he's
really into me too he's the only one for
me I just know it and I know just how to
get him amazing ears he'll be mine by
the end of the day I just know it I told
him that my house was on fire but once
he's there I'll tell them that I threw
myself on the flames to put them out
he'll be so impressed that he'll fall
for me immediately and once I have him
he'll be mine forever there is only one
thing that could possibly go wrong
wait wait what do you even what does it
even mean wait you told them already
that your house was on fire like now
you told them now that your house was on
fire Oh what world does that make any
sense
hugged how's it gonna believe you what
like you're just at school at the
beginning of the day you're like oh by
the way my house is on fire
I'll go check it out in seven hours once
I go home all right whatever okay
all right anyway I'm gonna
we're gonna keep going so if that was
4900 or 4900 then the next one to be
5600 so I need 5600 points next which I
could probably do with you and
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo how about a little
bit of what could I do
what can I do I can do the vent why I
can do more vent ones yeah I can do then
ones those are easy this is about
slamming the vent at the right time okay
you are through the vent as well so
that's 5,600 so I added scrap baby
venti boy and other event D ball is and
that should be enough
all right let's do 5,600 well let's get
this hopefully it gets another chain and
paid to do all this and not do that it
probably won't do my luck I'll get to
marionette
I'll do it what am I looking for doo doo
doo doo doo
uh-huh what is that what I just got your
guitar you [ __ ] you greedy bastard I
did the thing where I swept that's
surprised even me huh I swept again
goddamn it
ah man even even now like I makes silly
little mistakes like that I'm gonna try
that again I mean you're gonna have to
let me try that again because if I don't
try it again then I'm not gonna do
anything
oh don't know why I put that down put
that up up down yeah this is gonna be
sitting around thank you Cheyenne Taylor
a fan a fan Jamie seif doomed friend a
fan 101 thank you all so much for the
super chats and the sponsorships you
don't need to give me any super chat in
any way shape or form
oh my god really well I guess get it all
out at once as opposed to the
alternative which is ambushed me when I
don't need it
those guys are those guys are quick a
long night eh Thank You atlas Valentine
for the new sponsor Alexia Polson you
make me happy on my bad days very
awesome guy well thank you I don't know
about whoops oh well I guess you know
this is what I get for reading and not
okay we're good yeah thank you I show
Huffman lightning gamer you know mark
you could just slowly go through the
characters as you are and eventually get
to fifty twenty mode by the way longtime
fan actually no that's a lot of people
think that's the best way to go about it
not for me especially not for me
considering that I that's not how I
wanted to play the game anyway I for me
the game was learning the mechanics from
all of the characters at once it's not
that it's easier to go one way or
another the route that people go right
now and again not criticizing what it is
like it's it is what it is to do
whatever it takes to get to where you
want to go it's requiring it just uses a
lot of luck and a lot of um a lot of it
relies on a glitch that I think is
actually a glitch and I I don't think
it's a feature of the game but again not
criticizing do whatever it takes to win
I don't care but it relies on the glitch
of camera two for the plushy
animatronics for me the plushy
animatronics that is a feature of the
game and if you bypass that you're
exploiting glitch and again totally fair
I don't care do whatever it takes to be
at the game but for me personally it's
not satisfying to rely on luck when I
could just as easily have fun with the
game and do it by skill and I'm not
saying that the other people are not
doing are not skillful at the game
that's not what I'm saying like don't
take anything I'm saying out of context
but for me it was more fun to do 55
which was a really tough challenge and I
would encourage anybody out there do 55
it's a fun mode it it's fun because it's
it's just the right amount of all the
characters without being so overwhelming
that you feel like it's impossible and
it's just like it's totally within human
possibility to be able to get your
reflexes up to that point and so that's
why I like that mode going one character
20 mode at a time like I was saying when
I was playing it's it's it's going it's
using tactics that I didn't think were
representative of the game itself and
again not bad
everyone's gonna twist my words but what
I'm saying is that for me it was more
fun to do
away and not in any way easier or harder
make sense yeah yeah so I'm gonna be
forty-nine fifty but if like I've
watched some of those guys plan to get
deejay and Doc I've watched them play
and it doesn't seem fun it doesn't seem
in any way fun in me I was having tons
of fun and I didn't feel like a need to
do any more I'm only doing this right
now just to get some cutscenes for you
guys and personally I want to see it
[Music]
cutscene cus cus scene cut there we go
scene in order to get all those cut
scenes he must be 50 20 but oh I'm aware
of that I'm not gonna get all I'm just
getting some of them meaning cut it ahh
what does she know Timon he could he
knew him what a suicide when you
superstar Toki but as you are so good
news isn't done dog ouring bad of Thomas
Fox's Carnegie and divorce and has I
have strode to lost surge on his temple
time okay my attempt to overthrow the
Fuchs loose-knit filled Ellen's gonna
last longer I guess their failure come
with a new and horrible board and one
which I can hardly bear that he's a
buyer time this is for a week which
there's no linens I cut it on you hope
that soon suits but my under is a new
soon I Snuka dead fish into the pocket
of his rube he will be disoriented he
won't expect in a toque and never know
it's gonna put the delicious fish he
will love to how predictable burning to
suffer in this old newts the true
pursuit they should have learned this
loosen my ribs have never smelled so
clue
asking what the superest marks the end
of the bearing is clean just the things
that bear will regret the day across the
barrel goop is the goose the coops on
[Laughter]
okay um what am i doing I don't even
know anymore I I can guess I could do
foxy that wouldn't be too bad I can do
the plushy animatronics if they're like
at a 10 or something that wouldn't be
too bad
you and who's the other one a baby ah
62 okay let's get one more nut mass
please Oh Bonnie you're only in it oh
these guys are only at 10 I could crank
them I mean they weren't so bad one two
three one two three one two three and
the one ok 6300 thanks guys
yeah I'm glad I'm glad you're glad you
love my dramatic those things alright
I'm only gonna get like this one and
maybe one more cutscene and then I'm
gonna call it for the rest if you guys
want to see more cutscenes they're gonna
take more effort to do and I just don't
feel like doing the effort for this
one's probably still pretty easy though
I say you know with no confidence
whatsoever what am i doing
foxy you're there perfect I did the
thing
why am I not why don't I have it if I'm
winding the music box anyway why don't I
just have that enabled like it seems
like something logical that I would do
oh you are you're gonna get me in
trouble that's all right it's completely
farted all over that I had no idea what
I'm doing I gotta buy the deep fricking
plushie Gibby you fifteen no like that
Oh like that sam-i-am ho ain't done I
get it down these guys are just a
[ __ ] see this is what I mean it's
like it's actually gonna take me
concentrating on this one I don't feel
like here we go
Borobudur no not that one put you there
put you there why didn't I put like
another animatronic in there that would
be smart okay we're not gonna give me oh
yes please
Oh foxy right right that's something I
need to pay attention to hello who's
there oh I don't have enough I need one
more can I get one more one more please
nah can't get one more there we go I
forgot who was down god why are you hey
hey you so much
hey you so much alright let's go it
should not be done like this I'm not
taking this in anyway seriously and
honestly why would I but you know I'll
try not to be stuck in so much doubt you
know just try no promises on lack of
suck ass
can I please hit that can I be just a
little less suck ass is all I ask
nope no coins for me that's okay I
didn't need them that's all right I
didn't want now this might be the last
one I go for it just because get it
god damn you I had that I had that I had
that I need two more oh boy you [ __ ] you
let me let me I'm gonna get rid of I'm
gonna get rid of who I'm gonna add oh
these guys good God
why didn't I have these guys in these
guys are so easy and let me just put in
the night marionette because frankly I
died like I don't even want to like I
think that I'm already doing that anyway
so I'm probably gonna be totally fine
with that what do I need 63 I've
actually had too much let's stake out
let's take out the two of the plushy
dudes let's see who the plushy dudes we
only got this plush you do there we go
that's see if that seems more reasonable
that's definitely more oozing the Bulo
definitely are here we go
I got it I got it yeah I got it I need a
haircut
excuse you you know excuse you how rude
are you give me god damn [ __ ] and coins
I forgot about the winding things that I
got to do I'll do that winding thing I
forgot about that
oh oh oh yeah shut up where's your
guitar there it is whoa
all right okay let's see how you're
gonna be a little little friendly people
here son of a [ __ ] son of it you're
there why damn it I did the wrong button
all right guys this is where I'm stupid
does everybody hang on everybody just
chant how stupid I am like I'm
unbelievably stupid there we go there we
go
this is fine I got it
how did you get in I thought I had that
down had that down
Wow so stupid
let's stop it why mrs. stupid stop being
stupid there we go I'm so stupid I'm
forgetting like the silliest things
because it's for some reason like not
everyone
ruining my entire existence right there
because I keep thinking that things are
gonna be there and they're not Wow
why okay you're there
Oh Oh almost forgot the music books get
that guitar click you get shocked there
you are very marginally better not a lot
better though they say come at the same
time that's awfully nice of them oh well
that sucks
[Music]
goddamnit didi covering you like an
[ __ ] this is not hard I've got this
I'm just so uh thank you I'm a smart
smart smart ha you died so it's super
chatted $10 just say hot you don't know
I know that's not malicious in any way I
do you think it's really funny
I'm not calling I'm not calling out for
pudding let's just keep looking over
chat my god I got this hold on your
horses guys here comes me with my
incredible school
couple I'll put all that mask well that
mask baby boo saw that
why did I do that
I forgot I haven't why did the
flippy-floppy forgetting everything I
wish everything was just fifty ten I'd
be I think a better time at this all
right no I'm not gonna I'm not going to
talk I'm not gonna goof I'm just gonna
do what I came here to do and that's it
Oh
[Music]
too
good turn on the global music boxes over
there oh what the [ __ ]
god dammit I got flappy again why oh I'm
just losing it wait do I not have Bonnie
enable no screw you you are trying dude
you're sweaty you're welcome bastard
[Music]
deedy you son of a [ __ ] just shot of a
[ __ ] I'm going to rip my eyes out I'm
gonna rip my eyes out there's not art
why am I having a tough time with this
however it my eyes
[Music]
where is it
here's it oh god damn it didn't see that
Oh foxy I totally forgot about foxy I
totally forgot I totally forgot about
foxy I completely forgot
oh my god I'm such an idiot I'm so
stupid
I completely forgot about foxy I can't
believe I forgot about foxy ah so stupid
I'm so stupid I'm stupid stupid it's
open open all right let's try this I got
this I got this I got it if I could just
not be stupid I'd be great
[Music]
I'm over it I got it Abdullah
switcheroos I'm doing all this which
arose this is not that hard
and yet I'm scrubbing it I'm scrubbing
as hard as I can scrub
I've never screwed anything to the
scrooby level that I'm scrubbing this uh
yeah yeah I've never screw the uh Peter
so hard in my life
there you go okay back in the night if I
could just not waste too much power
I don't have enough coins I keep leaving
doors open which is gonna love my power
i'ma run out power cuz I kept aloof in
that oh come on
anyway I probably could have gotten
through that with something else but I'm
uh let me just take this guy out cuz
getting those coins is what's messing me
up here because I keep going the rhythm
that I would normally oh no not that guy
I keep going the rhythm that I would
normally go if I was trying to get like
check for different spots but I checked
I don't need to check because this guy's
not there and Rockstar chicas not there
so it's like why am i checking those
spots I don't need to check those butts
and yet here I go I'm checking the spots
anyway so I'm gonna make it up and I
guess I could do I'm gonna make it up in
oh yeah fun time foxy let's let's do fun
time cuz I'm checking there anyway no
that's gonna screw me over I know it's
gonna mangle of course the vent the vent
animatronics wait who else's event
animatronic was there another was that
it I think so anyway let's just do this
cuz I need to stop what the problem is
I'm doing my full strategy and it's not
working I got okay so the only thing I
gotta do is I gotta watch where fun time
foxy is there mangle is in the vents and
get this
well I guess I'll never see foxy why am
I going for coins again Oh God you know
just you know I'm gonna just
[Music]
let's just do that let's just do that
do I not why not that we do that I can
remember I'm not gonna give up because
this is not hard
this isn't hard this is easy this is the
easiest thing I can do and yet I'm
screwing it up because I'm being dumb
I'm being incredibly dumb so yeah I'm
not even doing the strategy where I
where I have like the AC gonna I'm just
relying on the fan because I'm trying
just being a lazy douche about it I
don't know why I don't know why okay one
o'clock one o'clock
god that's not harder Oh God
ah no I beat 55 yesterday I'm not going
to remember you right I'm just trying to
get one more cut seat and it's not hot
just being so stupid if I could just not
be stupid about it please I'm begging
you
oh now I go for the wind-up thing now I
go to the wind-up place I didn't put
these down because I'm stupid permit god
what am i doing I don't even know
anymore
Who am I where am I who took my pants
oh boy thanks
[Music]
music man I didn't think I put music man
in here oh I gotta go
then I gotta go back to doing the the
instant I start sorry I didn't know I
put music man in here oh then I gotta go
then I gotta go back to the the other
shadow I was doing which was just with
the the actual air conditioning which
would be fought what wait oh no she
added music man in there that's right oh
she added music man okay
dee dee go but I hole
[Music]
I'm a trying that
at this point I could have done the
whisper I knew I forget I knew I'd
forget get out of here I do I knew I
knew I so knew I knew it let's just put
you guys at five I knew it forget every
time I knew it I told you guys I was
like a boob you know every hour on the
hour every hour every hour on the hour
every hour on the hour and then what do
I do I don't every hour on my hours like
a jerk 100 you always catch me with an
ADD but I'm right there
[Music]
I so had that I so had that now whatever
god damn it I had that every time points
it's like this insane perfect timing for
like screwing me over
[Music]
God [ __ ] a dog [ __ ] my dog here take my
dog [ __ ] it [ __ ] this dog this is not
hard
no no I took out fund I'm foxy I don't
even remember every hour on the hour
every stupid goddamn hour on the hour
it is not hard the only reason I'm
losing is cousin
yeah because why why am I still to this
day I'm still going back to the toy
Freddy office even the toy Brody's not
there anymore was ready just left a long
time ago boy Freddy don't give a [ __ ]
toy Freddy don't give no [ __ ] about me
that's what I'm trying to say there but
I got interrupted
yes today is all about memes memes means
both bus boats memes memes memes oh god
damn it
I'm so stupid I'm so stupid
Oh mark try to win don't lose oh oh oh I
get it
oops I'm not gonna win if I do that what
am i doing so I could try to meme and I
lose immediately and I know I can do
this this is not huh this is so not art
ah so not hard
[Music]
oh I don't have enough really oh god I
need to get that goddamn plushie
let me get sucks no god [ __ ] my duck
I click the wrong plushie I click the
wrong [ __ ] plushie it's not no it's
not hard the only reason I'm losing is
because my instincts are going focusing
on the wrong things
I'm so stupid is why and every time I
lose it like I should have had this a
million times ago
[Music]
I will not I will not cheese a very
fortunate oh how I am stretching it oh
[Music]
god damn it oh that was my fault now
that was absolutely just me being stupid
like every other made so far no I got
this oh god damn it who did you add 63
70 was what it said it's not hard I'm
telling you it's not a oh she really
wants to have the music man you know
what just cuz it's cuz it's not hard I'm
a nice it's not this is not hard this is
super easy
oh yeah I got to do this I forgot about
that
Oh [ __ ] be oh oh oh
doh Oh doll not when I just go out I
[Music]
like you trying to go for that
but no I got that that's weird okay
every time I put that up it's every time
the screen up it gives like I've got the
timing perfectly I've got the timing
perfectly every time I put the screen up
it's just a [ __ ] ad huh and it's not
that it always does that when it puts
the screen up if you put like the ad
goes any time the ad is random time even
if the screens down it's looked at oh
this is why I didn't do it like this
because it's [ __ ] orange OOP [ __ ]
I'm fine I didn't do my things I needed
to do but that's okay because I did
actually apparently I did this is easy
there's not hard
I I'm brushing she [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] old man [ __ ] face old
man titty sprinkles [ __ ] you old man
[ __ ] yeah don't like you
[Music]
Oh give me some goddamn coins please
oh my god there's no one there
oh all of them are up old man [ __ ]
consequences no one's there though I
forgot it was up and down up and down up
and down up and down this is not this is
nothing this is like this is not five
twenty if it's not fifty twenty this is
not there's not anything this is just
trying to get a point said I'd and at
this point I could change up the
characters but now this is a point of
pride because I can do this so easily
and yet I keep forgetting the simplest
things that I learned already as I've
got this y'all know that I got this this
is not this is what you would call an
easy breezy beautiful easy this is easy
breezy beautiful this like a summers
sprinkle like a summer but hold on
that's what that's all this is
[Applause]
I forgot abou is up or down not God I
kids come touch sue is it cysts that
sees this thing just up II Downey
God why am I so stupid no God what the
[ __ ]
god no I forgot I D coined foxy just to
try to make my life easier and it's like
as soon as I try to do anything remotely
like a different and I'm like no just if
I have a separate thought that's not in
my rhythm I'll just completely [ __ ]
everything up I've got this no shut up
I got this that's not hard it's not oh
my god see that's that's called a
mistake right there I'm screaming it you
guys this is not not focusing on the
game I got let me get this I got this
it's all Gucci we got there ain't no
worry of care in the world
not a worry not a care no nothing to sew
[Music]
there we go god oh my god really I don't
need that okay oh [ __ ] why why I swept
Oh see every death is just as stupid
it's a stupid thing oh why do i sweep
why do i sweep across it's not hard
this is so easy this is the easiest
thing in the world and yet I'm dying
it's so pathetic it's not it's dad that
doesn't prove that it's easy it proves
that I'm an idiot huh just please let me
live let me live I just wanna I just
want to show Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so you're there every time I got every
[ __ ] John attention on the worst I'm
gonna kill somebody
I'm gonna kill somebody I'm gonna kill
you
spring-trap you think you can [ __ ] on me
not today mister
now what I'm destroying pissed off now
when I'm dis pissed off you get pissed
off at this level you get Thunder horns
I so had old man consequences there
did I get that Plus yeah okay we're good
we're good we're good
[Music]
not forgetting something oh I am
forgetting something god dammit the VINs
this vector more specifically God okay
got that and it should be good
no that's not what I wanted
[Music]
don't put that back up why would I do
that
wait oh [ __ ] oh my god every time I just
put that up every time
[Music]
easy I'm running out of power though for
some [ __ ] reason
oh hey you almost got me there ah not
today oh it's the other plushy all right
see how there are no trouble I gotta get
that now gotta get get it get it get it
reset oh my god get the I gotta get the
big guitar where's there it is and the
doors I was doing I was doing the fan on
just because it made my life easier but
at this point I'm gonna do my old thing
because I ran out of power because the
fan was on I do a thing where I just
juggle the you see and I wasn't doing
that originally because I was like I'm
better than this I'm gonna beat this
mono in mono it kiddo and then I see
but I didn't so you know nuts to that
idea well I saw your guitar I still
don't know why I'm going to a toy Freddy
zone
go away go away oh hi every time every
time this is not this is not hard this
is not hard this is not hard this isn't
even no god damn it I forgot I'd I
wouldn't have done it anyway because I
decoy in the wrong people or ad coined
the right people this is not hard guys
it's not it's not hard this is not hard
this is not hard everybody hold onto
your butts cuz it's hard
this is not hard this is not hard
well I was doing the depositing five
coins because I was doing the just
trying to be lazy about the the heat and
power management and instead of that I'm
gonna be smart about it
because another thing that the the doing
the AC manually does is it just keeps
you waiting here for just a little bit
longer cuz I'm just be enough in a hurry
bastard
try to be all fancy about it when in
reality I'm just doing myself a
disservice
so I saw something yeah I saw that
oh I was just hoping I remembered I was
just hoping desperately that I
remembered which way was up and which
way was down oh please just let me see
no oh well ah I'm going to kill mm
someone someone's gonna die this is not
hard I have this it's so easy it's so
unbelievably easy it's so redonkulous ly
easy
I had you
[Music]
all right I'm hitting see
click on the burden then I suddenly die
that would be the one way that I could
go
word of advice always don't play like
you're about to hit the time there we go
see that was easy that was easy
I don't know why it was cuz I was trying
to do like I was trying to be lazy about
it with the fan and the Legos it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but okay cuz I'll try it
yeah I'll send me fancy about that let's
try to be number one I was trying to be
fancy and number two I was trying to be
lazy so I'll be lazy and fancy at the
same time [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
all right let's see this what do we got
what do we what do we got what do we got
dear diary yesterday was so amazing the
fire wonderful guy Wow but I don't think
it was meant to last for my heart
belongs to another he's so amazing and
strong and so so cute
I've been thinking about him all day and
I think he's really into me too he's the
only one for me I just know it and I
know just how to get him well thank you
no look at those eyes those amazing eyes
he'll be mine by the end of the day I
just know it I told him that I've taken
several live hostages at my house but
once he's there I'll tell him that I let
them go because I love him he'll fall
for me immediately and once I have him
he'll be mine forever there is only one
thing that could possibly go wrong
only one thing only one thing you
actually killed all the hostages and
then you're in he's not gonna fall in
love with you because they were already
dead you let them go to the afterlife
that's what you let them go to wow that
was good
the only thing we got left is a big
batch it's very important everybody hold
on this is very extremely important big
bads is extremely important everybody
hold on this is you'll you'll see why is
it you'll see why you'll see why KUB a
big batch I don't think big batch
listens to the oh no he does alright
let's I just I've never dyed to pick on
some time see if you sit by the river
long enough you will see the body of
your enemy float by
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's I guess I'll see you again
anyway so man I I think that that's
probably for me and that's probably it
for all of ultimate custom night for me
I just wanted to see I've never dyed a
big batch before so I was kind of
curious of what it was gonna be like I
did with event I loved it I loved it I
don't think he hasn't a secret lines I'm
pretty sure that pick batch does not
have secret line so that's not about the
nail that sticks out gets hammered down
oh yeah and I get a new office that's
true I get a new office but that's fine
anyway so that is the end of ultimate
custom right for me I think I set out to
everything that I wanted to do that I
possibly wanted to do I don't want to do
5020 mode it's just not something that I
would find fun it might be possible I
think it's impossible but if it is
possible then like kudos to everybody
else that does it first I really don't
care so I wanted to also say a lot of
people were confused and saying that I
wasn't enjoying this game let me be very
clear I've already said this a few times
in this room but let me be very clear
this is my favorite custom night of all
of all these I didn't want to go about
the strategy of increasing 120 mode at a
time that seemed really really boring to
me and it's also seemed really really
frustrating to me the way I had fun this
mode right here was fun really really
fun like I enjoyed this mode a lot like
50:10 mode is probably doable with the
same strategy I had but still it's fun
like that's what it's all about
like that's what this game is supposed
to be about anyway it's supposed to be
about just enjoying your time in the
game like enjoying it like experimenting
with what you can I bet I could do 50 10
mode and I'm just doing it because I'm
curious like I haven't actually done it
ever and I'm just like how like what Oh
now I've completely forgotten everything
that I needed to do ah
I've already completely forgotten what
am i doing what am I supposed to do oh
yeah the music box oh boy
well you see I'm gonna die you still
remember I don't remember nothing oh
yeah so like I could do it I could try
it and I would be fine with that if I
got my strategy out that that seems
pretty tough but not that bad but in all
honesty I got everything I wanted out of
this game I've got other things I want
to do
I've been sick these past few days I'm
starting to feel better finally I'm
still sick today so I'm gonna go lay
down take a nap after this drink some
drink some day cool or something he does
have a secret line I don't think I don't
think he does I don't think he'd do it
wasn't in his it wasn't in his wiki like
if it's not in the wiki then I don't
think it's I don't think it's true yeah
wait yeah the talented hawk hides his
claws even monkeys fall from trees I
[Music]
consider it a dignified death not really
it was actually quite pathetic yeah it
doesn't seem like he has any other lines
besides that so I'm gonna leave that
there
this was a lot of fun don't get down on
anybody that's trying 5020 mode don't
like get down on anyone that's trying to
get there first don't get down on people
just because they're trying something
cool I would never [ __ ] on anyone like
just because they're doing that so why
would you do it either spread joy and
positivity why would you try to bring
anyone down to over a simple game so uh
that's all I'll say about that and I
hope you guys have fun with it play for
yourself this is a game like you should
play like it's it's just fun it's free
like that's not as amazing thing about
it it's free like this game is free what
Scott is done here is really cool and I
think it's just something to be enjoyed
never take it too seriously especially
when it comes to the lore of the game
like that's not what's important like
the important is that it's a game and
it's fun and it's interesting and these
characters are diverse and it's a good
time all around horrible time with all
the teeth and stuff but it's a good time
so never forget that you guys take care
I'll probably be streaming over on
Twitch later today just a casual stream
as I wind down
because I've been wanting to play games
lately and that's been a lot of fun so
if you want to find that you can find me
on twitch TV slash markiplier thank you
to all of the super chat I didn't get to
it later on as I was trying really hard
to all that stuff but thank you to
everybody that sponsored and super
chatted if I miss something I'm terribly
sorry I wish I didn't Tom Murphy of
50:20 mode equals too much [ __ ] I
tend to agree but I tend to agree yeah
too much [ __ ] in the game and too
much [ __ ] required of you as a
person so I AJ did a lot of with 200
super 10 foxy did the bite of 87 maybe
maybe it's possible I don't know but
thank you all nonetheless you guys take
care have a wonderful time if you want
to see more mediocre content like this
check out the other videos on my channel
and maybe subscribe to see more mediocre
videos puppet open your sub feed thanks
everybody so much for watching y'all if
you go over on twitch.tv slash
markiplier you might find me over there
just follow me over there if you want
maybe a few hours from now depends on
how long a nap so thanks again and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye bye guys have a good night
see ya bye take care love you smooches
mmm its Mouton smooches to you